International Rescue Committee has
warned that up to a billion people could
be infected with coronavirus across
crisis affected countries I spoke
earlier to its chief executive the
former Foreign Secretary David Miliband
you told me that the virus could claim
as many as 3 million lives around the
world we've studied the 34 fragile and
conflict affected states where the
International Rescue Committee works we
know the struggles that exist in
advanced countries like the UK or the US
but in these conflict torn States using
very conservative estimates on the
infection rate based on the Imperial
College and World Health Organization
data based on a assumption about Chinese
levels of hospital and health care which
is really very generous given the levels
that exist in conflict-affected States
like Yemen or Syria we've found that the
corona virus is going to affect between
half a billion and a billion people
globally in these 34 countries and that
the death toll could number up to 3
million between 1 and a half and 3
million and so our call is to say that
we have only weeks to prepare for this
disease to go on the rampage in some of
the poorest countries in the world and
as the debate about lockdown develops
and how to end it develops in countries
like the UK we need to make sure that we
recognize this disease is a global
disease that will only be fully beaten
when it's beaten everywhere now this at
the moment it's a dreadful prospect but
it's only potential what is the extent
of coronavirus infection as far as we
can tell in in these 34 countries well
we know that corona virus is now
everywhere we also know that the testing
regime for all the problems that exist
in the UK or the u.s. the testing regime
is threadbare in countries like South
Sudan in countries like Nigeria in
countries like Pakistan and so the
official toll at the moment which in in
Africa they're estimated according to
the number of tests is about only 25,000
cases across the whole continent about
more than a billion people we know
that's a massive underestimate what we
can see is that step by step there are
more and more people coming to our
health centers that we run around the
world and so we see this disease really
taking off by around mid-may and so we
can see it creeping forward we've got a
few weeks left to do some essential
cautionary preventative work that means
very basic hand-washing stations
it means triaging people by testing
their fever and isolating a high fever
cases but we're going to also have to
build up the health systems because
there's going to be an enormous number
of people who need basic therapeutic
care and where are the resources for
that going to come from well the
resources are gonna have to come
internationally one thing that we've
discovered in the last a few weeks is
that obviously countries like the UK the
u.s. they found money when they needed
it and our point is that as a matter of
morality but also as a hard-headed
matter about how we return to anything
like normality we're going to have to
fully fund the aspirations of
organizations like the World Health
Organization the promise of the Trump
administration to cut the World Health
Organization budget is the opposite of
what's needed we also are going to have
to make sure that in countries like
South Sudan where there's four
ventilators for the whole country we're
not gonna save lives by getting
ventilators in there we're gonna save
lives by getting much more basic
infrastructure into place so that people
can prevent the disease through hand
washing through proper information
through a modicum of social distancing
but also by isolating cases so they
don't spread across the whole population
so if the World Health Organization were
to be funded fully and most of its
members do fund it would that be
sufficient well the new appeal details
haven't yet come out we're gonna know
next week the global humanitarian
response appeal which is jointly being
done by different agencies across the
United Nations so we don't yet know the
full scale of their appeal but certainly
the underfunding that is promised by the
Trump administration is completely
retrograde it would damage some
absolutely vital programs not just in
respect of Cova incidentally but also in
respect of other matters 27%
u.s. funding for the World Health
Organization goes into eradicating polio
so there are other health conditions and
we've made the point that there's a
double emergency in developed in under
the in lesser developed countries in
countries where there's a very weak
health infrastructure yes there's a
health emergency but there's also a
social and economic emergency looming as
well where the weakness of the overall
economy means that the emergency is
doubled for these very vulnerable
populations and so the sooner we get on
with the preventative work the more we
can mitigate both aspects of the
emergency what do you say to President
Trump's suggestion that in warmer places
the virus may pose less of a threat we
don't have any evidence for that at the
moment there are warm places that have
had the disease remember the in
Australia it's been summer over the last
three months and they've had the disease
so I don't think we can rely on the
weather to sort this disease out it's
hit countries warm and cold it's hit
countries democratic and autocratic it's
hit countries north south east and west
it's a genuine disease of the connected
global economy and society and will only
attack and push this disease back if we
do it everywhere the biggest part of the
problem there's also been a suggestion
in countries where sanitation is less
good the population may have a bigger in
bill resistance to things like this
that's certainly the case in on one side
of the ledger but on the other side of
the ledger countries where there's high
levels of malnutrition where there are
weak underlying health conditions are
more vulnerable so it swings and
roundabouts on this that's why we've
given a range of a half a billion to a
billion estimates of infection in our
report we've also given the range for
the number who will eventually die
between one and a half and three million
because it depends on our response and
of course there's a lot that's uncertain
about this disease but what we do know
is that if you can't wash your hands if
you've got high levels of malnutrition
if you don't have a functioning health
system your
vulnerability is all the greater on the
other side of the ledger of course if
you've got a youthful population that
may help you but the vulnerability the
danger for people around the world
remains very high now on this question
you obviously I tried to provide some
leadership but if we look at national
governments you're critical of Donald
Trump but do you see a sufficient global
leadership coming from elsewhere not at
the moment no I mean it's to state the
obvious there is that this is a global
disease that's being fought nation by
nation now the UK has taken an important
step in convening a group of countries
to help think about the distribution of
vaccines when one is finally discovered
that's a good thing but we need much
much more of that at the moment the
group of seven leading industrialized
democracies haven't even managed to
agree a joint statement the group of 20
which is currently led by Saudi Arabia
which is 20 largest economies in the
world that is in a slumber that's the
only way to describe it and the global
nature of the disease is not being
matched by the kind of international
cooperation that is going to be
essential we can also see a looming
battle where you can see countries like
China or to classic countries or Thorat
Aryan countries saying they've dealt
with it better because they're
authoritarian there's no evidence that
that's the case because after all
democracies like Germany and South Korea
have done well but I do think that these
contests about the lessons of the
disease are being started now and the
debates about the lessons of disease are
being started now they need to be joined
by real action do you see China also
trying to exploit perhaps an
illegitimate opportunity for global
influence in this area undoubtedly that
every country wants that's thinking
strategically autocratic one yes I think
that you can see both in the benevolent
actions that China is taking for example
in the distribution of humanitarian aid
but also the tougher line they're taking
in their own sphere of influence in in
the region and in their own country or
the way they're cracking down on dissent
you can see there's a two-step being
a practiced and my point is that we
shouldn't be declaring a cold war
against China that would be a retrograde
and thing to do it wouldn't be a wise
thing to do but we do need to rally the
world's democracies to work together so
that they can negotiate compete and
cooperate with countries like China on
something like an equal basis because
given the size of China you're right it
isn't emerging superpower but if you
balance that with the scale of the
European Union 500 million people plus
the UK plus the US population you've got
some kind of balance there and I think
if the you if the democracy of the world
don't cooperate they're gonna be on the
backfoot when it comes to a more
confident China which we're undoubtedly
seeing but what does it say that the
United States which has been the leader
of the free world for at least a century
the biggest economy in the world the
most advanced society what does it say
for democracy the United States is also
the worst-hit country but it says that
there is a high degree of dysfunction in
the way the American response has been
organized some of that is built into the
separation of powers between national
and federal and state authorities but
obviously there's also the degree of
polarization that has created the
massive level of mistrust that exists
across the country here I'm living and
working in the u.s. I'm obviously a
British citizen and I see a high level
of polarization and mistrust and one of
the things that we know about this
crisis is that it requires high levels
of social trust for an effective
response countries like South Korea and
Germany have shown that the rallying
that's happened in the UK to support the
National Health Service 750,000
volunteers that speaks to social
cohesion we're not seeing that in the
u.s. at the moment even before you get
into the absurdities of last week's
discussion about bleach and it's ill
effects and so I think that there's a
big question now that America is going
to have to confront how does it combine
a more effective domestic response with
a reassertion of international
leadership and in an election year that
needs to be a big part of the debate